Well,
we start with a story in development
since on Wednesday night
a shooting occurred involving an agent from
the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department who is greeting you
Christian Casares Las Vegas' Buda Bar
was closed for several hours and a
man  is in critical condition
after being shot by a subway officer
on wednesday night this incident
occurred over las vegas back
near sunset officers had
initially responded to a call from
a woman for help when
suddenly this man got out of a vehicle
and started shooting the officers
responded wounding the suspect he
tried to flee but was caught and
taken to the hospital for
up to two weeks the board of directors of
the university education system voted
to maintain the mandatory vaccination for
the workforce it is recorded that more
than 96 percent of the staff  one
way is fully vaccinated listen to
this employees of n  s h not vaccinated
or who do not have information for
an exception should be vaccinated
by December 31 or they will lose their jobs
on Friday the board of directors will discuss
the mandatory vaccine for students
a special session although everything could
change and an April says that the
percentage of students  vaccinated is
more than 90%
and after we continue with the
schools since as of Friday the
park county school district
announced that it will take a five-
day break due to the increase in cases due to
kobe technically they would be free on
Friday and Tuesday already  that Monday is a
holiday yes yes he reported that
2,300 cases have been reported since the start
of the new year and we close that report with
a look at the weather as we can
see we will have a
partially sunny day today with temperatures
reaching 66 degrees by the  tonight
we will see some clouds and
some breezes are expected for Friday as
the temperatures will drop for the f  In the
week I am Cristian Cásseres with his
brief informative of Spanish ignition
good day
[Music]